[Música]
Bienvenidos a Francia en poco su cita
con la actualidad francesa por las
pantallas de France
[Aplausos]
[Música]
un proyecto de ley pretende inflamar los
debates en la asamblea nacional francesa
a partir del próximo año el proyecto de
ley de inmigración en el centro un
nombre
el ministro del interior francés que se
presentaba con el ministro de la firmeza
Pero eso hasta el 11 de noviembre pasado
cuando recaló en el puerto de tulón en
el sur de Francia el navío humanitario
Houston viking con 230 migrantes a bordo
después de ser rechazado por Italia el
ministro pasó a ser Entonces el
humanitario la gestión de la crisis
estuvo lejos también de tener mano dura
de los 200 migrantes que esperaban
regularizar su situación en un recinto
cerrado No queda hoy en día ninguno
es el próximo gran obstáculo en el
Horizonte para el gobierno de Manuel
macron la ley de inmigración que debe
ser debatida en el parlamento a
comienzos del 2023 pero este otoño la
actualidad le tendió una trampa al
ministro del interior con el caso de
lawson bikini
en la línea de Mira del gobierno un
proyecto de ley inflamable por lo que
muchos temen ya que pueda servir a los
intereses de marine penn todo Estaba
previsto sin embargo Con lujo de
detalles primero una entrevista en el
diario lemundo a comienzos de mes para
anunciar las grandes líneas del proyecto
y Mostrar la firmeza del gobierno con
los clandestinos
hasta las consultas de todos los grupos
políticos pero eso fue antes del caso
del Ocean viking
[Música]
lago
en la mayoría presidencial miden los
daños políticamente y en términos de
imagen las situaciones catastrófica dice
un consejero ministerial
ragal juega el sheriff con resultados
que son malos Agrega una diputada de la
izquierda del oficialismo al contrario
la polémica del Ocean viking muestra
bien que la ley de inmigración Es
indispensable concluye otro diputado de
René el partido de gobierno Pero cómo
hacer votar esta ley sin mayoría
absoluta en la asamblea el macroismo
sabe que el análisis del proyecto de ley
de inmigración será una prueba la clave
los diputados del partido de los
republicanos dice un dirigente de la
mayoría presidencial pero la derecha no
le hará ningún regalo a macron No creo
que al mismo tiempo de macron sea
posible en materia migratoria creemos
más inmigra menos mucho menos nosotros
estamos por la segunda solución si los
republicanos no votan el texto el
gobierno estará obligado a utilizar el
49 3 como una demostración de impotencia
que según la oposición no dura nada
bueno macron no quiere ser como Obama
que llevó a Trump al poder analiza un
líder de los republicanos Pero al final
está poniendo la alfombra roja al pene
un 37% de los franceses ve positiva la
acción de María le pen solo Eduard ex
Primer Ministro la supera las ongs están
muy preocupadas con este proyecto de ley
por eso el gobierno las ha invitado a
los últimos días a realizar una
concertación lo que más les inquieta es
que el gobierno ha prometido hacer más
eficaces las obligaciones de abandonar
el territorio francés el tema está muy
candente después del asesinato de Lola
Una niña que murió a manos de una
argelina que estaba obligada a dejar el
territorio galo otra medida en cambio
atrae más a las ong Y es que el gobierno
ha prometido dar permisos de residencia
temporales a los migrantes que ejerzan
un oficio calificado en Francia como en
tensión
en la hostelería o la restauración los
servicios a la persona la agricultura o
en la construcción cerca de 800.000
puestos están vacantes en estos cuatro
sectores este año para combatir la falta
de mano de obra de oficios llamados en
tensión el gobierno quiere crear
permisos de residencia para los
trabajadores
en esta construcción en la región de
París están con retraso en una obra como
esta tengo dos personas cuando debería
tener seis este capataz debe renunciar a
nuevas obras le faltan fontaneros y
electricistas las únicas candidaturas
que recibe son de extranjeros sin
documentación prohibición entonces de
hacerlos trabajar pero si este proyecto
de ley de inmigración es adoptado podrá
contratarlos
creo que eso nos va a facilitar tener
mano de obra aceptar proyectos es
magnífico pero si no podemos asegurar la
producción y el seguimiento no sirve de
nada
según la televisión pública el gobierno
espera entregar permisos de residencia
de un año a estos trabajadores
habrá que probar una antigüedad en el
territorio un ejercicio de un oficio Que
aparezca en la lista de oficios en
tensión pero eso responderá a las
necesidades de la economía y sobre todo
a una necesidad y una voluntad de
construir un proyecto personal familiar
si la reforma pasa el trabajador podrá
el mismo pedir su regularización hoy
solo puede hacerlo el empleador por el
momento el proyecto hace Hablar a la
oposición tanto de derecha como de
izquierda
es el mejor medio de hacer venir a otros
extranjeros en situación irregular
llamarlos a venir porque tendrán la
certeza de que serán regularizados
hay que regularizar a todos los
trabajadores extranjeros no veo porque
solo a los sectores en tensión el texto
será debatido en el senado desde enero
próximo
el 24 de noviembre algunos días después
de la llegada de la usan Bikina Francia
se cumplió un año del naufragio de una
embarcación en el Canal de la Mancha en
que murieron 27 migrantes los habitantes
de dunker que recordaron a los
fallecidos mientras una investigación
del diario lemundo apunta a la
negligencia de los cuerpos de Socorro
franceses
justo un año después de que 27 migrantes
murieran en el Canal de la Mancha
cientos de personas antorchas en mano
marcharon en una plaza de dunker que en
el norte de Francia bajo el lema
vuestras fronteras nuestros muertos
y luego se leyeron uno a uno los nombres
de los fallecidos
es importante recordarlos hablar de
ellos pensar en sus familias y también
denunciar porque eventos como este
pueden ocurrir y pueden reproducirse en
cualquier momento
es un fracaso total de todas las
políticas de seguridad que son puestas
en marcha en Europa y particularmente en
Francia y especialmente en esa frontera
entre Francia y Gran Bretaña la
investigación policial aún no arroja
resultados sin embargo un reportaje del
diario El Mundo deja ver la negligencia
de los servicios de Socorro franceses
que no escucharon a los migrantes pese a
sus sucesivas llamadas
y para terminar los vamos a llevar de
viaje al sur de Francia la dor Doña
donde un castillo tiene unos jardines
impresionantes y unas actividades
reservadas para los más usados
una decoración vegetal para quedarse sin
palabras Colgando de una roca que
sobrevuela la dordoña el jardín de marca
Isaac tiene 150.000 arbustos
cuando llega el otoño hay que podarlos a
mano con tijeras creando una sinfonía en
dos tiempos
[Música]
no hay que cortarlos simplemente repasar
los brotes que ha habido en la temporada
son esculturas de forma geométrica
christop jefe de jardineros se preocupa
de los detalles
somos muy precisos sobre el tamaño por
eso utilizamos una tijera a mano con un
golpe limpio preciso la hoja es bien
cortada y no se destruye
un gesto milimétrico que encanta Los
visitantes
es joyería Es verdaderamente hermoso es
minucioso delicado y al mismo tiempo
magnífico
cuando es plano es más fácil que cuando
es redondo y hay que seguir las curvas
Son ellos los verdaderos profesionales
no tienen plano no tienen nada Es
verdaderamente bonito
arbustos que cortar no solamente en la
tierra también hay que ocuparse de la
vegetación instalada en este acantilado
la primera vez que uno baja la verdad se
tiene miedo uno tiene una bola en el
estómago efectivamente
pero nada queda al azar estos jardineros
del extremo fueron formados para este
ejercicio particular
atados con una cuerda trabajan aquí a 15
metros del suelo
[Música]
ya es difícil cortar en Tierra Firme
entonces cortar haciendo acrobacias en
acantilado es aún más complicado
pero no solo los jardineros tienen
derecho a las sensaciones fuertes este
dominio de 22 hectáreas es muy conocido
por los turistas por sus instalaciones
deportivas sobre todo esta vía ferrata
un itinerario instalado en un acantilado
rocoso con vista sobre el río de La doña
a cambio de un cierto esfuerzo físico
[Música]
una hora de recorrido
a veces incluso suspendido en el vacío
un recuerdo memorable
para los que se atreven a lanzarse en
esta aventura
es muy rico en sensaciones el recorrido
no se hace solo hay que poner de uno
fue muy lindo estoy muy contenta de
haberlo hecho es muy único encontrar eso
en un lugar cultural de jardines debe
ser muy único en Francia y en el mundo
creo mientras la última visita el
castillo se inicia antes de que caiga la
noche bajo la mirada atenta de los pavos
reales es Estefanía quien desde hace 20
años explica la historia de este lugar
Qué forma tenía este Jardín en esa época
Y cómo Hemos llegado a esta forma que
hoy descubrimos y les recuerdo que aquí
no hay planos Entonces no puede ser
copiar y pegar de los jardines de antaño
Los Jardines de marque Isaac datan de
fines del siglo XIX y atravesaron el
tiempo
en el origen del proyecto un juez Julian
de serval
[Música]
150 años después todavía disfrutamos de
su obra de este jardín que creó completo
porque él plantó e hizo plantar estos
arbustos durante 30 años su Rincón de
paz es nuestro Rincón de paz
abierto todo el año los turistas se
hacen más raros en otoño después de seis
kilómetros de paseo relajación
garantizada
Es verdaderamente magnífico uno está en
otro mundo sí es hermoso
es muy agradable un jardín con estos
acantilados Y tenemos la suerte en
noviembre de tener un buen tiempo como
este
año el jardín tuvo un número récord de
visitas 210 mil lo que hace de él el
jardín más visitado de la región del
perico
y hasta aquí este capítulo de Francia
enfoco Muchas gracias por su compañía y
hasta una próxima por las pantallas de
France 24 o en France 24.com